so last time we started talking about
the simulation
this time let me ask you do you think
there's intelligent life out there
in the universe i've always maintained
my answer to the
fermi paradox i think there has been
intelligent life elsewhere in the
universe
so the intelligent civilizations existed
but they've blown themselves up so your
general intuition is that intelligent
civilizations quickly like there's that
parameter
in in the drake equation your senses
they don't last very long
yeah how are we doing on that like have
we lasted pretty
pretty good are we do oh yeah
i mean not quite yet
well what was that telly has your casket
iq required to
destroy the world falls by one point
every year
okay so technology democratizes
the destruction of the world when can a
meme destroy the world
it kind of is already right somewhat
i don't think i don't think we've seen
anywhere near the worst of it yet
world's going to get weird well maybe
you can save the world
you thought about that the meme lord
elon musk fighting on the side of good
versus the uh the meme lord of the
darkness which is uh
not saying anything bad about donald
trump but he is the
the lord of the meme on the dark side
he's a darth vader of memes
i think in every fairy tale
they always end it with and they lived
happily ever after and i'm like please
tell me more about this happily ever
after
i've heard 50 of marriages end in
divorce uh
why doesn't your marriage end up there
you can't just say happily ever after so
it's the thing about destruction is it's
over after the destruction
um we have to do everything right in
order to avoid it
and uh one thing wrong i mean actually
this is what i really like about
cryptography uh cryptography it seems
like we live in a world where the
defense wins
um versus like nuclear weapons the
opposite is true
it is much easier to build a warhead
that splits into 100 little warheads
than to build something that can
you know take out 100 little warheads uh
the offense has the advantage there
um so maybe our future is in crypto but
uh so cryptography right the goliath is
the
the defense and then all the different
hackers are the
uh are the davids and that equation is
flipped for nuclear war
because there's so many like one nuclear
weapon destroys everything
essentially yeah and it is much easier
to uh
attack with a nuclear weapon than it is
to like the technology required to
intercept and destroy a rocket
is much more complicated than the
technology required to just you know
orbital trajectory
send a rocket to somebody
you